more pics tumor gentleman mein name ist
sie mich ich komme aus dem schönen ulm
und ich habe da eine frage an dich
gentleman aber vorab möchte ich der
große druck für dein letztes album
aussprechen was liegt die das hat mir
ziemlich gut gefallen vor allem die
finishline und die lieder mich durch
gute und schlechte zeiten begleitet und
dafür möchte erstmal ford danken
meine frage an sich ist du hast meine
zeit lang gekämpft hat zugesagt und was
war so leer punkt wo du gesagt dass er
so kannst dich weiter gehen das ist der
tropfen der das fass zum überlaufen
bringt das wird mich interessieren ich
danke schonmal vorab und mach's gut und
auch ein hai sehe mich freut mich dass
dir meine musik gefällt das album
diversity es gibt aber noch ein neues
album der new day dauern um auf deine
frage zu kommen was das kiffen angeht
ich finde das ist eine ganz persönliche
entscheidung und jeder muss für sich
herausfinden wie er damit umgeht
bei mir war es einfach irgendwann so ich
wollte einfach wieder was mit kriegen
oder mehr mit kriegen ich habe mich dann
so ein bisschen in der wolke verschont
so und mich hat das kiffen nicht zum
schlechten menschen gemacht so und ich
hatte auch mobil gute zeiten und ich
würde auch niemals nie sagen aber ich
merke einfach im moment ich fühle mich
so besser ich bin ein kommunikativer ich
habe mehr energie und vor allen dingen
kann ich mich an meine träume erinnern
so das konnte ich in der zeit nicht so
gut beziehungsweise eigentlich gar nicht
ich fühle mich lebendig trotzdem kann
ich auch verstehen wenn man sich dann
irgendwann mal wieder klein machen will
sie aber in dem moment wo ich mir
bestimmte dinge vornehme und auch viel
zu tun habe und hohe ziele habe fällt
mir das leichter
die ziele zu erreichen wenn ich mir
nicht die hose weg dampf so und ich war
vor allen dingen auch nicht der typ der
ab und zu mal joint rauchen konnte dann
denke ich immer so wie wenn ich das
könnte so manche leute rauchen ja ab und
zu mal ein oder abends 19 können ich war
so der morgens aufsteht typ1 wirbel und
das dann am abend also ich bin sehr
exzessiv in meinem konsum
das hat mir dann irgendwann nicht mehr
gut getan meinte five costa möchte
wissen wie findest du es dass seine
musik auch in jamaika also dem land des
reggae gehört wird wird gehört wird
fühlst du dich geehrt also ich muss
sagen jamaika kommt auch sehr gut ohne
mich aus und trotzdem ist es natürlich
eine motivation und vor allen dingen
inspirierend dass meine musik in jamaica
ankommt das sie songs im radio laufen
und das ist natürlich etwas was mir
extrem viel kraft gibt vor allen dingen
auch in zeiten der zweifel bei zweifel
auch immer natürliche begleiterscheinung
von dem sind was ich tue
mozy 39 möchte wissen was war dein
schönstes erlebnis
mein schönstes erlebnis war oder ist
eine ganz schwierige frage also zum
einen ist nicht schwierig weil es gab
wirklich mehrere schöne erlebnisse wenn
ich das jetzt wenn ich jetzt eins
benennen würde dann wäre das den anderen
ungerecht gegenüber und zum anderen das
allerschönste erlebnisses musst du immer
für dich behalten so sonst verliert an
magie ich will jetzt nicht komplett
enttäuschen
musikalisch gesehen würde ich jetzt so
aus dem bauch sagen das woodstock
festival 2011 in polen wo 700.000
menschen vor der bühne waren der erste
song von mir der im radio lief die
geburt meines sohnes die hochzeit
ich weiß es nicht gibt einfach irgendwie
jeden tag schön im moment muss einfach
nur nach suchen noch 20 fragt welche
bedeutung welchen hintergrund hat juge
member you remember ist ein song wo es
darum geht dass ich einfach dinge aus
der vergangenheit vermisse und dinge in
der gegenwart sehr schätze und ich bin
überhaupt nicht jemand der sagt das
internet das ist alles kacke sondern ich
nutze es auch und sehr viele viele
vorteile ich sehe aber auch viele viele
nachteile
und es ist ein aufruf kritisch zu
bleiben es ist ein aufruf sich auch zeit
zu nehmen und miteinander zu
kommunizieren und nicht nur über
facebook und smsen sondern
wer sich wirklich mal zu unterhalten
auch zeit sind entschleunigen nicht so
schnell sich fortzubewegen um überhaupt
was mitzukriegen darum geht you remember
mails chat hat folgende frage wollte
wissen wie du zur musik gekommen bist
wie bin ich zur musik gekommen
ich weiß es nicht wirklich also es gab
da viele viele stationen die ersten
moment ist wahrscheinlich die du so
unbewusst wahrnehmen es nämlich dass du
ein stück musik hörst und ich das
unglaublich berührt zum einfach holen
muss oder lachen musste und ich weiß
nicht wann das war
dann gab es natürlich meine verbindung
zur reggae musik und die finger an durch
die platten meines bruders und parallel
dazu gab es ein kumpel der aus jamaika
platten mitgebracht hat alle platten
dies hier nicht gab
ich habe musik kennengelernt die sehr
radikal politisch sozialkritisch ist und
trotzdem so süß ist die sehr
traditionelles und trotzdem am zeitgeist
dran ist hat mich einfach immer mehr für
die musik interessiert und habe gemerkt
musik ist vielmehr als entertainment
sondern musik ist etwas spirituelles
und es gab viele stationen die mich
hierhin geführt haben pöppel li na wenn
du ein tier sein könnte ist welches
wärst du gerne ein vogel ich wäre gern
vogel also ich beneide immer die vögel
und denkt immer so kalt dass schwere
coupé die ratten an die fliegen da
einfach um die können einfach
irgendwohin fliegen die zugvögel wenn es
dann kalt wird dann fliegen die einfach
im süden und kommen dann irgendwann
zurück vogel wäre ich gerne